hello welcome back did you know that
world of warcraft is still kicking along
I do because I've been going to support
group since i quit about four years ago
every day since they keep priming at
those expansion packs warlords of
Draenor Justin it is just to give you
the most possible entrances in a segment
really nailed it there buddy it is a
game that is hard to give up them used
to be a part of a guild back in the old
one updates called can't quit you I
can't quit you girls pretty good but
Julio here is been putting a lot more
time into it we talked about this on a
live stream yesterday warlords of
draenor is coming out soon I think we
might be giving away some codes we are
in fact before we start this one of the
good folks at all know that they can get
in on this right now if they go to get a
tab ready you ready all right gamespot
com /wel giveaway go to that page right
now and there you can get access to the
beta for your very self we have a bunch
of codes we are not that's the smallest
link in its cells emit it's tiny if
you're watching this on your phone I'm
sorry just type well give away it's not
even that hard yeah it's pretty good for
a dead giveaway I believe in you we've
got more inches of them nobody else
knows except the people watching this
stream so just get in there now and get
your beta codes and yeah we're gonna
we're going to show it off right now
yeah and you'll be able to play exactly
what we're doing here so the way they've
set up the beta is that you're able to
actually just create your own level 90
character like you don't have to go
through anything because we're just
testing it out right coolio yeah yeah
they give you one level 90 when you buy
the game and well sets as beta we can
make as many 90s as we want that's the
level cap no no one hundred yeah so so
if I play through the the previous
expansion you can get up to level 90 and
to make sure that players are able to
you know start experiencing that the new
stuff that they made they're going to
give you a level 90 when you I'm give
you when you buy the game you can have
one character that's set to level 90 and
one of the interesting things they're
adding for this expansion is the ability
to buy more level 90 characters like you
go really it's like 60 bucks right it's
annoying i hate that's BS that's happy
to be aggressive this it should be
shaming them slice it worse than just
giving them a free level 90 it's because
you can stack more love lines that you
did some anyway that's deep dive I want
to I want to get let's get into it
what's new in Orleans Draenor why is
this
something that I want to go back and
play oh my goodness so that is a big
bowl okay the most notable thing that
you know people are going to notice is
the new graphics right new character
models models yeah it's an only
character models or they updated any of
the environments whatsoever uh well
they're making a new world right during
or yeah which is basically what outlands
was before it became outland yeah so
that's all brand-new uh but this is I
guess a much bigger deal actually made a
video on this can we roll it yeah yeah
we gotta move we got a video on this bad
boy Oh what comparing all the new yeah
here we go gonna put a video in your
video all right stop covering your face
we can see your face all right there you
go so it's harder to see the comparisons
I think when you're just looking at the
new models but when you look at them
side by side there's there's a distinct
difference between the way these
characters previously looked yeah that
was really exciting off the line and
challenged by this dwarf in the last
minute of this of this gameplay demo
people do we have the other ones yeah
yeah let's just keep going on these bad
boys this is a tiny person I want to see
less the eyes got bigger less dwarves
and more more big old models the faces
look more details yep when you go in
close you can see even more more changes
but yeah everyone has this full screen
right now now that you're seeing all
these animations yeah oh yeah so there
are still more characters yet to be
revealed with their you know their
updates okay the game has doesn't have a
release date you know we're assuming
it's gonna be sometime in the fall and
before that they'll show off how all of
the new character models will look okay
that orc does look more muscular yeah
they say that's more badass let's paly
Guinea polygon II but everything else
looks the same like there's no like new
ice storm wind or line forage or no the
world it said the regular world that
you'll be visiting is pretty much the
same I don't think there's gonna be a
huge overhaul yeah that no that would
just take the way too well for a game
that came out if I'm right it was 2004
right so we got like a decade ago it's
it's it's looking all right yeah no it's
looking pretty good now they made a they
took a gamble going with this our
cartoony art style and they were paying
for it so much in the beginning yes but
in the end that's really paid off like
that this holds up better than a lot of
more realistic looking game that's
actually a really good looking torrent
yeah look how much better that looks the
alarm looks so bad okay let's hop into
the game we've had enough of a core get
out of Ironforge there
we spent some time with this uh the
other day yesterday kind of playing
around with some of the the new starting
area but uh you know there's a few
things that they're introducing to this
uh like Garrison some new things are
gonna be able to play around it but you
don't get to jump into those right away
okay the first things that we played
around with our they're pretty similar
to the rest of the wow that you've been
playing like you know kind of explore be
honest this is the wow everyone
remembers where are we now for folks who
don't know this is this is what you are
okay in burning crusade this is hellfire
peninsula okay portals right here right
so in burning crusade this area's all
like destructed and red and it looks
completely different right now I oh my
goodness ah that Panther jump is just
really believe you're gonna owe your
morale hell fire looks like wow yeah
yeah totally don't mind this you know
does it look like Hellfire man there's
all grass growing around and stuff like
that do you know who remember the
Hellfire looks like I can't believe it
Jurgen Klinsmann yeah Oh anyway effing
Utley cannot believe it and so in this
game you're actually traveling backwards
in time so this isn't like a different
version of this world this is actually
that original part of the world but
thousands of years promoting the
integrated buttoning that's nothing new
to warcraft that happen in bc as well
right I remember when they started doing
the well at lands I guess was that
traveling to time talking clear that was
traveling to a different day present day
no there was that what do they call them
the instance although time stuff oh yes
man I forget whatever so long oh yeah
getting to experience moments of the
past yeah but this is literally being in
this entire world like you're
experiencing the world in basically the
way that it was back then and for people
that have been really into the game it's
probably not something that's gonna draw
in new players yeah but getting to
experience that lore firsthand that
people have been reading about or in
skipping over whenever you get a new
question cool if anyone has any
questions by all means in the twitch
chat gamespot shaft and we'll stop
screaming about other stuff matter for
about a five-minute break but don't
worry about it I think that's actually
something going on right now awesome
insertive awesome in-game event
happening dude just got 20,000 XP you'll
be just like yell where
that event at oh oh oh I think I
understand you were on your head this is
the event all right let's get here you
are getting evented this is the event
horizon run to the docks just gonna sit
here listen to sit on your bud take a
drink Julio you are so contrary alright
let's go get to the docks so what else
we got new in here even if it's stuff
that we can't see to explain and the new
Garrison's and stuff like what are you
upgrading is it one for yourself is it
when your client can have your operating
buildings that exist in the game world
what's going on so at some point within
the within the warlords of draenor
expansion you're going to be able to
build a garrison which is basically
building a house it's not something new
to MMOs but it's something new to our
old of work right I'm one that's been
asked i think since the first expansion
pack and this is a place where you'll be
able to get quest you'll be able to
build it up and to make your own
individual house bigger and stronger and
be able to add things that you wouldn't
have access to in other parts of the
game do you know where that lives like
Shirley in some instance know where
world right you can't just plop one down
the middle of the Elven forest yeah it's
gonna be instance but you I think you
can have it in different parts of durian
or you can choose where it's at so the
it's one of those things that you can
see but not of course not everybody can
see it because I would just make a
ridiculous world but you can invite
other people to it so it'll it kind of
like the the way that the world deforms
around you as you complete some quests
you see a different version of World of
Warcraft than other people see and
that's kind of how your uh how your
garrison will live we will be able to
invite other people to it you'll be able
to see it when you're walking around but
we're assuming but other people aren't
going to be bothered by having your
enormous meddling in the middle of their
place was that awesome world event just
a firestorm to get you all to run to
this dance party oh here we go yeah I
barely noticed the meteor so it kind of
just rode in my Panther over there it's
pretty majestic that is this sort of add
the camera taking cinematic stuff this
is an in-game cinematic this is I must
assume they're gonna add audio later
right is that stuff new I haven't played
the past in cinematic yeah not sort of
thought not really
they've been doing this for for the past
few expansions what one thing that is
interesting is that you lose the ability
to fly when you come out to this version
of your right which I'm missing a lot of
people off is it it's people are split I
think I think the more hardcore people
are are happy with it because you're
going to meet a lot more people out
there in the world yeah when you're not
up in the sky yeah flying by yourself so
I think that's all right it just depends
I think they're not completely set in
stone on whether or not they're even
going to allow flying injuring or all
right it feels like eventually they are
that's gonna be something that unlocks
again but it's it's not gonna be for a
while that would be kind of ironic
considering that's where I'd line was
where you first learned to fly out
exactly but it does get you closer to
the ground get you you you see more
people because when everyone's flying
then yeah and I imagine it's harder to
make a world where you're able to fly to
everything because then you just float
like you don't you don't try walking you
don't explore anything you just kind of
fly from one point to the other kind of
feels like you wouldn't be as motivated
to make like a nicely winding path with
like well-placed shrubbery is if you
know everyone's just as the crow flies
but at the same time once you lose a
flying like it's it is so freeing and so
much more fun to tip fly from one spot
to another kids it's so much faster
going back to just traveling on the
ground feels slow as if this isn't just
likes not getting killed that is well
there in the sky right I played like PVE
I don't have to worry about that and
there's a bunch more content as well
another are doing the usual shake up
with dungeons new dungeons at these
mythic raids as well are they just like
really really difficult big party raids
oh man when those bad boys are really
what our myth agree so apparently there
are much more difficult raids but i'm
not sure if they're like 10 party
difficult ones or if they're like large
difficult when it's not heroic I don't
know anything let's bury baby no I know
they've had a great race before that
yeah take enough magic to so welcome one
interesting thing from this is that this
is part of the larger plan to release
more regular content by yeah they even
said specifically what we're going to do
this every year but they have hinted
that that's part of the plan or at least
one of their ideas that they're going
for is is if not yearly at least really
really regularly instead of having
patches like norm
we went an expansion like this comes out
it'll be a significant patch that comes
out eventually which that's more content
ads more things to do and instead of
having a big patch they're just going to
go for for a full-out expansion because
that's the thing that it brings a new
players and gets people it's also the
things you can charge a bunch of money
for and have midnight launches for and I
worked about four or five min launches
for web stuff I'm over the years and
they always get a had a big bunch of
people queuing up for these like it's do
you think that they would still do that
at at this point I mean I feel like
world of warcraft more than anywhere
digital as a digital download spot like
when i was playing certainly and like
and the folks that i used to play with
having the physical like think about a
blizzard or one of those companies are
still like massive limited edition
version yeah that's true like diablo and
stuff like games that people are only
ever going to you know like probably
have the same problem wish did you go to
the midnight launches back in the day
yeah yeah just take your coffee you know
that used to be awesome yeah it's be fun
I still get those big limited edition
boxes just because they're they're so
nicely done I don't usually buy a
limited edition of a game but for the
world of warcraft ones i usually World
of Warcraft and Starcraft and Diablo
like they're just those thing heavy
boxes I like putting one you have yet
you have a shelf spot keep them on they
look kind of nice all in a row like
they're adhering to the same kind of
form factor but different art I
appreciate that they're the same every
year you don't have to worry about like
suddenly one has different they've got
your number hahaha big time yeah when is
warlords of draenor as for everyone so
we don't have a edition okay it's
sometime in the fall wait you know
usually this hits before blizzcon and
you know we're thinking that if they
want to do the big raids that they
normally do at blizzcon this is gonna
have to hit before then so you probably
expect to get into this for everybody to
be able to get into this before before
blizzcon at least the the beta keys that
were handing out you do need to have
mists of pandaria already installed so
you too okay this is not going to be
something that you're just able to grab
a key and I haven't been playing World
of Warcraft at all for a while I can
jump in you do we found out you being
disciplined area okay to play it
apologies anyone who I didn't say that
to beforehand and but yeah I do have mr.
pandas I bought it like i buy every
expansion pack and then played about 10
minutes and then forgot how to install
them so thanks you're welcome visitors
is this gonna bring you back in seeing
ever
a single expansion by two comes out I go
back and play a bit of us but I haven't
had a proper hook on any of them I think
catechism was the one that I went back
and played for a couple of months again
and maybe four or five months but I have
I don't know what do you think it's
wrong what would what would bring you
and keep you back into it they think
about where that makes me not want to
play it is that I feel like I'm wasting
time that I could have been spent
playing newer dead different games so I
don't know anyway anyway I believe it's
extra time and US game so we're gonna
get the hell out of here so we can watch
the rest of the game Thanks to everyone
for tuning into the lobby to speak text
everyone on the back thanks to these
awesome dudes where's my flag thank you
guys for watching marriott.com / Wow
giveaway if you want to get in on the
warlords of Draenor beta here if you and
you have misty ped uart I don't have a
SAP and area that's why I'm so upset
about yeah did the thing that just Oh
only you had miss all right everyone
univision com we'll see you there see
you next week thanks hang in the lobby
you
you